in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Lindley
and Evangeline I got it Evangeline has
it did I say that right yes welcome you
guys good idea where you from Katy Texas
near Houston Oh fun good to have you
guys welcome to Nashville here to do a
debt-free scream absolutely how much
have you paid off something close to
four hundred thousand Wow and how long
did that take eight long years got it is
that includes your own yes cool line
what was your range of income through
those eight years 140 to 200 way to go
what do you guys do for a living I'm a
Drilling Engineer petroleum petroleum
chilling engine okay excellent well
congratulations you guys so you paid off
your house absolutely yes how does that
feel
liberating you don't have a house
payment you're weird
that's awesome very well done so tell me
the story what happened eight years ago
that puts you guys on this Trek well
eight years ago I opportunity came up
for changing a job but before that we
had taken financial piece and we started
that mm-hmm but if that eight years ago
then the company did a background check
and credit check and I said well all
this kind of money or they don't let me
utilize their millions and millions
hundreds of millions of dollars - are
they gonna trust me so we need to clean
this up oh good for you okay very cool I
need to say to that first of all we give
to the Lord our tithes and offerings and
we support a lot of ministries and it's
just um we have learned and we realize
that we can never out give the goodness
of the Lord
that's very true that's impossible to do
very well done well congratulations you
guys so you've got a got a game plan and
you began to attack the debt and then
start that certainly included your
tithes and offerings your giving and
what do you tell people the key to
getting your for
hundred thousand dollars paid off in
eight years is B deliver it and
steadfast now to mention to that right
we sent kids college three of them at
the same time oh wow that's enough to
put a dent in the budget right there
cash let cash flow them excellent no two
new cars and grand vacation okay so here
you are you live like no one else and
now you don't have a payment in the
world not of one how long have you two
been married 33 years oh we have to the
same exact time as Dave and Sharron very
good man we owe no man but to love them
I love it that's great
in the 33 years you've been married have
you ever been debt-free until now in
1988
okay for a short period of time it
sounds like because if you leave Dover
sees oh okay okay everything was sold
off you were living overseas working I
guess okay and then you come home and
right back into the quote American
nightmare borrow money for a car etc
etcetera yeah exactly
very cool well congratulations you too
I'm very proud of you very well done
you're officially weird no house
payments you can do anything you want to
do an increase your giving you'll be
able to do whatever you need to do very
well done Lindley and Evangeline Houston
Texas $400,000 paid off in eight years
making 140 to 200 count it down that's
house and everything
let's hear a debt free scream very good
well done well done well done I love it
great job well I'll tell you what you
pay off your house you can do your
debt-free scream in the old way you want
to do it I love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up
that your broke friends think you've
lost your mind